rock le rock enfin consacré à lille 21h
hier soir ils sont venus ils sont tous
là le public dans une salle comble et
des personnalités préfet élu est
déléguée à la culture plus habituée des
orchestres philharmoniques des guitares
électriques thedan philippe léotard
trépigne mais la star c'est jack lang
venu soutenir l'aéronef cette petite
salle de rock récemment menacé de
disparition
né dans la quasi-indifférence il ya huit
mois hier tout le gratin culturel a
enfin offert et une descente dans les
entrailles d'un lieu sans gravité le
slogan de l'aéronef salle pilote en
france qui n'a d'équivalent qu'à
poitiers jeu le ministre que je savais
que je les y en a moins
j'ai 45 ans fait 33 il est loin le 78 le
temps rend l'écouté tout qui choquera
dessine aussi changer car le tournoi les
patineurs du ch en métal dans le succès
ne faiblit pas déjà trente mille
spectateurs à son actif et plus de 700
hier pour philippe léotard bientôt 50
ans acteur chanteur poète écorché vif
frère de l'autre et amoureux de l'île un
33 tours enregistré dans un studio
lillois
richard le croit et l'aéronef choisi
pour son premier spectacle sur scène
l'aéronef plébiscité et qui malgré un
procès intenté par les rives 1 restera
encore trois ans dans ce quartier chic
de lille avant de déménager